welcome to entertainment tonight
everyone betty white's passing at 99
still seems way too soon for someone who
was as vibrant as she was 100 and today
we're learning new details about betty's
final hours
i believe she was never afraid of death
because she really felt she'd be with
alan
betty's final words according to close
friend vicki lawrence was just one a
name alan
love of my life
a tribute to her depth of love for her
late husband alan ludden he's still so
very much around i swear he's sitting in
this chair
they had a remarkable marriage it didn't
last long enough
betty and allen were married for 18
years they built this home in carmel
california in 1978 before he died of
cancer we just made up our minds that we
were going to make the most of the time
we had
oh hi there i'm betty white
betty gave a crib style tour of the
coastal property in 2017.
this is the kitchen
those are
for the dog
the home is 3 600 square feet and
estimated to be worth more than 2
million dollars but it was her brentwood
home where betty spent the last few
years for betty's safety she
she stayed home
the legends longtime friend and agent
jeff witches says betty was comfortable
there even when i got her offers
when she flew to do the proposal with
sandra and ryan she didn't want to go at
first because she didn't want to leave
her house and her dog
as for funeral plans thank you for being
a friend
we're told arrangements are being
handled privately and witches is denying
speculation that betty who died of
natural causes could be laid to rest in
wisconsin that's where her beloved allen
who's from there was buried in 1981. we
had a crush on each other
now something really cool that's
happening is that fans are hoping to
honor betty on january 17th which would
have been her 100th birthday with the
hashtag betty white challenge they want
everyone to pick a local rescue or
animal shelter in your area and donate
just five dollars i'm in you're right
i'm 100 absolutely two hands